all right let's bring in chris mannix
kind enough to join us got a busy
schedule busy morning the sports
illustrated nba senior writer
what did you make of last night's win or
should i say loss
by the lakers well i mean you start with
denver once again showing that they have
a poise that belies their years i mean
this is
a different setting a different opponent
but the same nuggets team that
responds to resiliency and you know
watching that fourth quarter dan when
you see
lebron start to come on and start to
play the way he did it's like
it's like when you watch what tiger
woods used to do or tom brady used to do
where
you assume that somebody else is going
to lose but
for jamal murray to react the way he did
and respond
uh it's just another you know kind of
layer
or testament to uh to jamal murray i
think for the lakers
i mean there are a bunch of different
takeaways one is that every game the
lakers have lost
they've shot like 28 or
or worse from three point range it was
like 16 17
in portland game one uh 27 28
uh in game one against the rockets and
last night it was like 23
so there's a clear formula to beating
the lakers slow them down from
three-point range
and you've got a good shot to beat them
and i was talking about this in the
first segment of this hour and that is
you know you're in the bubble so we've
sort of taken away that ambiance that
can intimidate a young team
and you're finding that a lot of these
teams you know the celtics are young the
heat
has a lot of young players denver is a
young team they're not intimidated
you know denver to me doesn't come back
from 3-1 against the clippers if
they're actually playing in los angeles
at staples but in the bubble
it's kind of neutralized that and and
you sort of see this they
they didn't look like they were panicked
last night i don't know if they can come
back and win this
but i don't discount them and it feels
like it's easy to sort of slap them away
and say nah you got no shot here
you know that i thought lebron and the
lakers looked tired last night
and i think because of these games that
you know there's no distance between
you know games three and games four and
it
and like you know the bubble fatigue as
well i mean i just i think there's a
real
and you knew this you were in the bubble
you know it can
it can you know kind of eat away at you
here but
as you see the lakers as we move forward
any issues with this
you know that this is just a hiccup last
night or is there still a pattern there
you're concerned about
it's not so much a pattern that i'm
concerned with with the lakers
it's just the nuggets are really good
and they're capable
of winning this series i mean denver's
probably you know sitting back going to
practice today thinking we should be up
2-1
you know if we don't have a blown
defensive coverage at the end of that
game too
where you know mason plumlee does
something on that that screen
that he shouldn't have done uh they
could be up to one the series
and firmly in control i think if you're
the lakers in addition to finding ways
to get your three-point shooters more
open and more accurate
you've gotta win the rebounding battle
right like you can't play
dwight howard javale mcgee and anthony
davis as many minutes as they do
and get beat 44-25 on the glass i think
those three players
i believe combined for four rebounds
like you just can't do that if you're
gonna
if you're gonna play big you better
control the glass in the way they've
done in previous series or else
you might as well play a d at five for
the duration of these games
i call this a pivotal game four tonight
with the heaton celtics nobody calls it
a pivotal game for manix but i do
but i think that if the heat win tonight
that they're winning this series
and if boston wins tonight i think
boston might be winning this series your
thoughts
it's so strong take their dad pivotal
game four yes
i like that um thank you i if boston
loses
i don't discount them from coming back
um i think a lot of people got wrapped
up
after game two in some of the emotion
the celtics showed there was a lot of
comparisons i read
about last year's team last year's team
genuinely didn't like each other like
did not want to be around each other
this year's team is totally different
that you know losing game two the way
they did
that frustration combined with being in
the bubble for two plus months
it just all kind of boiled over this
teen years team likes each other
plays well with each other and is
capable of winning any single game in
the series i think this game four though
comes down to jimmy butler in a lot of
ways i mean jimmy butler
is like kind of a slow starting car like
he he kind of gets it going early in the
first three quarters
and in the fourth he's going all the way
trying to get his shots and
trying to take over in games he's
averaged dan in the regular season
around 12 13 shots per game
he's averaged in the postseason around
12 13 shots per game i think for miami
to win
he's got to average more than that he's
got to be in the high teams
maybe even the low 20s to prevent miami
from getting into another one of these
big holes
that they can't shoot themselves out of
so i look to see how aggressive jimmy
butler is in game four and that
will dictate how this game goes butler
is sort of the opposite of paul george
that that he gets started in the last
six minutes of the game where as
playoff paul sort of disappears then
that brings me to the clippers
i start to look at the makeup of this
team and let's just
and maybe we're on the same page denver
will be a better team next year
portland will be a better team golden
state will be a better team
lakers will probably be status quo if
not a little better
and then the rockets might be better or
status quo
which leads me to the clippers what do
the clippers do
because is this roster good enough that
they have this year
to win a championship next year
i do think it is and i think it would be
panicking to make any kind of
substantial changes
i think the clippers their biggest
off-season issue
is going to be being able to afford key
role players
like montrez harrell who's going to get
a big offer this summer
or this off season and marcus morris
who's going to get
at least a solid one year off from
somebody
uh this offseason steve ballmer is gonna
have to reach deep into his pockets
to you know come up with the kind of
money needed to pay the luxury tax
uh that this team is going to have to
pay but i don't think you change
a single thing i was as disappointed as
anyone by the clippers
you can't lose a series when you're up
three games to one simple as that
especially not when you have a player
like kawhi leonard but given the the
strangeness
of this season and the the problems the
clippers had
when they got to the bubble with so many
guys being missing early on
with mantras harold not even playing
until game one of this series
i don't think you your reaction to this
loss
is let's change everything now next
season yeah
no doubt dan the biggest season in the
history of the clippers franchise
if they don't at least get to the finals
you could see
that team broken up i mean paul george
and kawhi leonard
can become free agents doc rivers an
enormous season for him i had a gm
texted
me that said doc rivers has taken this
team exactly as far as vinnie del negro
has
like he has got to take that team deep
and prove
that he's that championship caliber
coach they thought they were getting
next season is everything that's all the
marbles but i don't think this season
you make a change it's just too many
outside the box
unthinkable variables happened that that
interrupted this season
billy donovan to the bulls how
surprising
not surprising you know i had talked to
billy briefly
after uh oklahoma city lost
in that game seven and i never got the
sense that he was
he wanted to get out of coaching for a
year take a break or even go back to
college
i think billy donovan wanted to be
associated with the team with a plan
and at that point oklahoma city which
wanted him back
they didn't really have a plan they
still don't really have a plan for how
that team's going to move forward are
they going to
keep chris paul and build around him are
they going to trade chris paul blow the
whole thing up
and start from scratch billy donovan
took over that team in 2015
and they were a championship contender
they had kevin durant and russell
westbrook
five years later i don't know what they
are the bulls
are not a good team right now but
they're a team with the plan they've got
arturus karnasovic
a very respected top basketball
executive leading things now
they've got good young talent and zach
levine lowry market wendell carter guys
like that
and just as important in the summer of
2021
when otto porter comes off the books
some other contracts come off the books
they can be players in free agency and a
good chicago team
uh is going to be an appealing place to
go for some free agents so
the bulls aren't perfect but at least
they're a team with a plan and that's
what appealed to billy donovan but where
do we stand with philadelphia where do
we stand with new orleans where do we
stand with indiana are they waiting for
the
the playoffs to be over uh at looking at
other candidates
possibly um it's a little surprising
that philadelphia hasn't moved on tyron
lou right now
i i think ty lue just makes too much
sense for that situation he's a guy that
has
a proven track record not just in
winning championships or a championship
but in dealing with big ego players
right like he coached the lakers or
coached the cavaliers
with lebron uh he's been on doc rivers
staff in many
different stops coaching big name uh
stars he can handle
the challenge that is joel embiid and
ben simmons it
it makes me wonder what philadelphia is
doing if they haven't acted
on that i think with indiana and new
orleans
it's a lot of mike d'antoni mixed in
there i think mike d'antoni is a strong
candidate for both jobs
and it may come down to which team makes
him the best financial offer
before i let you go next season when do
you think next season gets started
you know i've said for for weeks now dan
i think martin luther king day
january 18th is is a reasonable starting
point
i think the nba would love to start on
christmas but as you heard adam silver
say
december just doesn't seem likely and
that has everything to do
with the union not wanting to rush this
season start
after finishing in mid-october uh martin
luther king day
you can you can start that day it's a
good starting point for the nba i don't
think they go
a full 82 games i mean everybody in the
league office i've talked to has said
we don't want to compete with the
olympics that means getting out in
mid-july
is paramount so if i had to guess right
now and as we all know it's incredibly
fluid
i would say january 18th and it's a
60-something game season
that gets the league done by early to
mid july at the latest
but are we looking at the potential for
another bubble
season not a bubble season
but if the nba doesn't believe
they can get back in their buildings
they will do regional bubbles
i mean the league has regular conference
calls with nba general managers
and the ones i've talked to have said
look this is right now for where we at
we're at with everything going on
regional bubbles is
atop the list like that's what we're
planning towards
in the beginning of the season now three
months from now if we get into december
and there's a vaccine and there's a
window to getting
fans back in the stands in february
everything changes but right now they're
looking at regional bubbles
and we've talked about this before where
it's one month in a week to 10 days out
rinse wash repeat until you can get
things back to normal
oh what is normal thank you chris uh we
appreciate it we know you got a busy day
thank you i'm in my kitchen dan there's
nothing normal
yeah but you don't do anything in your
kitchen other than do interviews you
don't
cook right it's not true i i put salami
on wheat bread at least once a day what
is in your what's in your refrigerator
right now
salami that's it and beer like oh like
over
over three pounds of salami beer and
uh uh soapy water that's that's it
basically
you know you live the dream you live the
dream man
it is it is something you're inspiring
all of those kids who want to grow up to
be an nba
reporter you're really inspiring them
right now this is how you live
be about that life thank you bud that's
chris mannix sports illustrated nba
senior writer